in last year's review of the 5k imac we
told you guys to wait until next year
and if you're one of the people who did
congratulations because the 2025k imac
was worth the wait so let's get right
into this review
we've been using the 2300 model for
about a week
while we've been patiently waiting for
the high-end imac
with the new 10 core cpu and the 5700 xt
graphics card to get delivered
and during all of our testing of this
imac we've realized that this less
expensive model
is so good that for the first time ever
we're actually recommending this one for
a lot of people
but before we get into why this imac is
so much better this year
and on the other hand why some people
should actually
avoid this 2020 imac despite the massive
improvements
i want to first talk about why we told
you guys to skip last year's imac
even though it outperformed the 5 000
imac pro and many of the common tasks
that we do on a daily basis
while also being over two thousand
dollars less expensive
there were three reasons why we told you
guys to wait the first was the fact that
the ports did not change at all
it still came with the slow sd card
reader and there wasn't an option to get
a 10 gigabit ethernet port
even though apple added it to the less
expensive mac mini
and thankfully we now have that option
on the 2020 imac
and the sd card slot now supports much
faster
uh s2 transfer speeds but it would have
definitely been nice to have a couple of
extra thunderbolt 3 ports
the second reason was the fact that the
2019 imac was the only mac
that didn't come with apple's t2 chip
and that was very important because it
caused the 2018
15-inch macbook pro to destroy the imac
in terms of hevc video editing
even though the macbook was
significantly less powerful in terms of
raw performance
and now we finally have that t2 chip
and not only that but the 2025k imac now
comes with amd's
navi based graphics which come with
their own hardware accelerators for hevc
footage
as well as allowing us to connect not
one but two of apple's 6k
pro display xdrs and the last reason was
the lack of a redesign after eight
long years and while the imac obviously
didn't get redesigned this year
at least apple gave us a 1080p webcam
which definitely looks much better than
before
so a lot of our issues with the 2019
imac were thankfully fixed
with this year's model but some
unfortunately weren't
like the lack of a redesign which is
very important to a lot of people
so i'm going to talk about that as well
as the significance of apple switching
to their own apple silicon max
later on in this video but how about we
start with
the good news first the 2020 5k imac
comes with a few very important features
that make it so much better than last
year's imac including the switch to
intel's
latest 10gen processors and a few cherry
on top features
that i mentioned earlier like the
updated ports the 1080p webcam and
a couple of display features so let's
get into those
apple is now offering a nano texture
glass option for 500
which is basically a high-end way of
getting rid of glare and reflections on
the display
without messing with the colors or the
contrast and other reviewers
have been loving it but we don't
recommend it for most people since we've
personally never had any major issues
with reflections and we think that the
500
would be much better spent on different
upgrades another new feature is the
addition of apple's true tone technology
which automatically adjusts the white
balance of the display to match your
surroundings
which could be helpful if you're using
it at night but we don't recommend using
it while editing photos or video
since it can throw you off while color
grading and interestingly
the 2020 imac is the first one ever that
supports
hdr video playback but other than that
you won't be able to tell this year's
imac from
last year's model it's really what's on
the inside that counts
so let's get into that we initially
ordered the higher end imac with the
brand new 10 core cpu in the top of the
line
5700 xt graphics card but we were
disappointed to see that it wouldn't
ship for another two weeks
so we did something that we've never
done before we ordered another one which
is what this review
is all about and we couldn't have done
it without support from you
our viewers so thank you guys for
subscribing and ordering our apple
product merch
like this t-shirt and our new mask
right here from our merch shelf down
below thank you guys
this imac is the 2300 model with a 3.8
gigahertz eight core cpu
the 5500 xd graphics card with eight
gigs of vram
and a 512 gigabyte ssd which actually
comes
included this year compared to having to
pay a hundred dollars for it last year
so that's definitely a plus and as far
as the ram we left our imac with only
eight gigabytes because apple lets you
upgrade it yourself
without voiding the warranty and it only
takes a couple of minutes
so instead of paying apple six hundred
dollars for 32 gigs
we bought a 32 gig kit on amazon for
only 120 bucks
and if you want to do the same we'll
have links down below what really
impressed us was that apple pushed
this 8 core cpu to its limits allowing
it to use up to a massive 160
watts of power compared to only 120
watts
with last year's 8 core i9 imac and
instead of running at a stabilized clock
speed
of 3.75 gigahertz this one ran at a
consistent 4.45
gigahertz this allowed this year's 2300
imac to destroy last year's high-end
imac
and even the 5000 imac pro in terms of
cinebench r20 cpu stress test
and then for graphics power like in
unigine heaven's gaming test
this imac was nearing the performance of
those two imacs
at a much cheaper price now those were
just benchmarks
where it really gets impressive is when
you start looking at real world
performance
like for photo editing with lightroom
and video editing with final cut pro x
the imac destroyed a similarly priced
16-inch macbook pro
in terms of exporting and lightroom
classic and it was right behind
the imac pro which is really impressive
but for video editing
this imac absolutely killed both of
those machines
in almost every single test the only
area it was succeeded by the imac pro
was for c200 raw exporting since it's
very graphics heavy
and the imac pro has more raw graphics
power but of course
you can easily upgrade the graphics on
this imac if you have some extra cash
and it'll still be well below the price
of even a used imac pro
now what makes this year's imac really
special is the addition of the t2 chip
and navi based graphics so let me show
you how important that is
last year's imac got absolutely killed
by the 16 inch macbook pro
in terms of hevc video editing because
it lacked the t2 chip
so we actually recommended the macbook
pro for a lot of people
but this year the imac wins in basically
every test
thanks to that chip and the navi based
graphics now have new hardware
accelerators
that can decode 4k hevc at up to 90 fps
instead of the t2 chips 60fps and 1080p
video
at 360fps and it can even decode ak
video
so you can watch it on youtube without
putting any kind of stress on your
processor
now you might be asking why does hevc
video editing matter
well h.264 is currently the most widely
used standard video format
but hevc or h.265
is quickly becoming the new standard
because it gives you the same video
quality
while using significantly less storage
space in fact
your iphone now defaults to recording in
hvc video format
and heif photo format and canon's brand
new eos r5
camera records its highest quality video
using hevc
and sony's brand new a7s3 camera
supports hevc recording
in any mode which is one of the reasons
why max ordered
not one but three of those cameras for
us to use
and because these new 2020 imacs are so
good
in terms of hevc editing we ordered two
of them
this model to replace our editor
angelica's imac
and the higher end model to replace my
five thousand dollar imac pro
now if the 2020 imac didn't have an
option for a 10 gigabit ethernet port
i would 100 stick with the imac pro
until the larger apple silicon mac came
out so basically
we've just established that these new
imacs are by far
the best macs we've seen in years in
terms of performance
however there's the apple silicon mac
switch
which i'll get into in just a minute and
there's also a chance that apple
will release just one more intel based
imac pro
before the end of the year now you might
be asking why
who in their right mind would buy an
intel-based imac pro
knowing the apple silicon is coming soon
well the only way i can make sense of it
is if apple makes it so good that
high-end developers will be swept off
their feet so if the imac pro does in
fact get refreshed
it'll most likely come with amd's big
navi graphics card
it'll come with intel's recently leaked
10 nanometer ice lake xeon chips
with up to 28 cores it'll come with
wi-fi 6
and most importantly it'll be the very
first apple product
to come with a mini led display this is
actually what i predicted in a video i
posted on june 11th
based on claims from analyst ming chakro
that apple will release an
updated 27-inch imac pro in the fourth
quarter of 2020
which means no redesign as well as
packing an intel processor
so hopefully i don't totally fail on
that prediction but if it does get
refreshed with a mini led display
big navi graphics and new 10 nanometer
xeon chips
you can bet that people are gonna be
buying it despite the apple silicon mac
transition
but it's also gonna be priced at at
least 5 000
so for a lot of you guys that aren't
high-end developers it really doesn't
make sense
so let's finally get into the most
important topic for this review
apple switch from intel cpus to their
very own arm-based custom silicon chips
the great thing about those future macs
is that they'll have all the great
hardware accelerators
like the t2 chip built into the main soc
or system on a chip this means that even
the lower end max
will handle hevc video editing very well
in fact
our 2020 ipad pro handled canon's
unconventional
422 format perfectly well while our 15
000
mac pro struggled and i can guarantee
that the brand new
family of apple silicon chips will be a
whole different beast
compared to the a12 z chip in the ipad
pro
likely packing hardware acceleration for
a variety of different formats
and those chips will also come with
apple's custom neural engine and machine
learning accelerators
which you just can't get on an intel
based mac and i'm
almost 100 sure that apple will
implement the same hardware accelerators
from their mac pro's afterburner card
into the higher end apple silicon max
so basically those new macs are gonna
handle every apple app including final
cut
logic pro xcode and more and they'll
likely do it better
than the previous intel intel-based
versions of those macs and what's really
reassuring is that apple has been
working
directly with adobe and microsoft for
months now
making sure that not one but all of
their apps will be running
natively on apple silicon so if you're
like us and you mostly only use
those apps then apple silicon macs are
going to be great for you
especially since they'll be totally
redesigned and fresh
so it may be a good idea for you to
avoid the 2020 imac
and wait for the apple silicon model but
if you use other third-party apps
i'm honestly not sure how well they'll
work during this transition period
and of course bootcamp support is going
away
so if you're a windows 10 gamer waiting
for apple silicon
is a bad idea now the biggest dilemma we
have right now is that a lot of people
like the 27 inch imac
and not the lower end imac and i'm 100
certain
that the redesigned apple silicon imac
that's been rumored to come later this
year
or early next year is actually going to
be a replacement for
the 21 and a half inch imac and i've
been telling you guys that for months
now
and it's been basically confirmed by the
fact that apple for the first time ever
updated the 27-inch imac without making
any real change to the 21.5 inch imac
except for ditching the hard drive so we
should expect a totally redesigned
24-inch apple silicon imac probably
within the next six months
and i actually have a pretty good idea
of what that's going to look like
and i'm going to make a video on that
very soon so subscribe right now if you
want to see that
but as for the 27 inch imac getting
redesigned with a larger display
and an apple silicone chip it'll
probably be at least another year until
that gets released
or maybe even longer so you definitely
could wait for that
but you can't spend your whole life
waiting to buy something
because there will always be more leaks
and rumors
so just like dave lee said in his review
if you need an imac
right now you buy one right now and this
2020 imac
absolutely kills in terms of performance
especially for what we need them for so
that's why we bought two of them
even though we plan on buying the apple
silicon models on day one
and we're extremely excited to test the
performance of the 10 core model
which is going to be delivered this
thursday so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this review and if you did
go ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe and be sure to check out our
apple product merch
down below thank you guys for watching
and we'll see you in the next one